images that show the beauty of an
extreme sport one that's always
overshadowed by the specter of death
barely a season goes by without a
freediver dying but for the creators of
the film not cause free diving is simply
the most amazing sport in the world
we're trying to have a another point of
view to what we're letting is we are not
showing we're not showing records or
deep diving we're trying to emphasize on
on the beauty of the sport here in Nice
on France's Mediterranean coast free
divers Julie Gotye and gil melle prepare
for today's shoot with stretching and
breathing exercises at a depth of 100
meters lungs shrink to the size of two
oranges do lot breathing exercise a lot
of stretching exercise in order to
accept this pressure the key of Dupree
diving is to relax and accept if you
fight against the pressure you're gonna
feel the pain and it's going to be
uncomfortable and you can urge yourself
the two free divers have been a couple
for several years having met through
their sport they branched out into
filmmaking four years ago with their
first video free fall inspired by BASE
jumping videos it shows Guillaume
Nettie's free fall in Dean's blue hole
in the Bahamas
Geum was in the barman's for the
competition and we had this camera and
so yeah we have a good camera we should
make a movie I'll ok you just take the
camera and we made we made people that
we have now 18 million views it's just
crazy their internet fans finance the
couple's latest project through
crowdfunding now cause was made more or
less on their own doorstep here in the
Bay of V far sewer mouth and in the
mountains near the court deserve the
short film deals with the hallucinations
that free divers can have on very deep
dives the classic rapture of the deep
caused by nitrogen narcosis once he or
merely had a vision of marrying his
girlfriend visions and the norcos ease
and the rupture of the dips are not
always funny sometimes it's kind of
scary and when i'm a bit anxious before
the dive it can be a nightmare down
there today they're doing test shots for
new videos julie Gotye has always been
fascinated by the rapture of the deep
that she's never yet experienced it
herself it's especially strong during
dives of 90 meters or more during their
shoots great depths don't play a role
here it's about their collaboration
underwater and how the lack of heavy
diving equipment makes it special you
have a freedom of movement underwater
Julie when she's homing me she can
follow me up and down she can go to the
same speed she can turn around me and
free diving the sports reading his
freedom so filming on free dating is
filming with freedom after the test
shots they head back to their apartment
on the outskirts of nice where their
two-year-old daughter mallu awaits them
this season Guillaume nearly is taking a
break from competitions and world record
attempts one reason for that is the
death last autumn of an American free
diver your man truly want to use the
time for more film projects now cause
will soon have its premiere and they
hope it will be as successful as free
fall so if we expect too much we're
going to be disappointed so an
expectation even if deep inside the home
and we are like I we hope as he's going
to be successful again but the internet
will have to wait a little longer for
now cause because its first going to
screen at various festivals but in the
meantime the two will soon be uploading
a video they shot in the underwater
world of french polynesia